Council and commission statements
conclusion of the European council
meeting of the 26th and 27th of October
2023 and the European Council and
commission statements humanitarian
crisis in Gaza and the need for a
humanitarian pause and I would like to
give the floor now to the president of
the council M Mr Miss Char Michelle you
will
play
ladies and
gentlemen nothing nothing can justify
the terror and cruelty that Hamas
Unleashed against the people of Israel
on October
7th over 1,400 innocent men women and
children slau and over 240 people taken
hostage and how much brutality does not
stop there in Gaza they are using
inocent civilians their own people as
human Shields one thing is absolutely
certain we can never let such a
terrorist attack happen again countering
Hamas will take more than military might
it will require a strong coition of
regional and Global actors bending
together with one common cause to fight
terrorism Hamas must not have any future
in governing Gaza ladies and gentlemen
dear colleagues we support Israel's
right to defend itself and it must be
done in line with International
humanitarian law the EU stands
unequivocally for the protection of
civilian life each civilian life matters
always and everywhere a total SE is not
in line with international law we call
for humanitarian poses in corridors in
Gaza because humanitarian Aid must get
to those in need urgently and the more
the situation deteriorates the harder it
will be to work towards the lasting
peace in the future with each passing
hour more lives are broken more families
turn apart we must work and we are
working to help alleviate the suffering
and I especially commend France Greece
Cyprus and some others for their
concrete actions like a maritime
hospital and a maritime Corridor and in
the meeting in Paris tomorrow we will
discuss and decide more support finally
ladies and gentlemen
we must not lose sight of the bigger Jal
picture the EU can help the Middle East
while also continuing its strong support
for Ukraine for as long as it takes both
regions need our continuous involvement
and that's why I propose that the EU
purchase grains from Ukraine and ship
them to those in need in the Middle East
this is a strong strong gesture of
solidarity and
efficiency ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues Israelis and Palestinians
both have the right to a peaceful and
stable tomorrow so we must have a vision
for what comes next a vision for what
tomorrow could look like and I'm
absolutely convinced with all of you
that we must bring back the prospect of
lasting peace in the region and let's be
honest for years for years huge amounts
and efforts have been pumped into
security
but nearly but not nearly enough has
been invested in peace and even less
into Justice and
Reconciliation and this approach did not
work peace peace means security but
security does not always mean peace one
without the other only feeds more in
stability for both Israelis and
Palestinians alike the EU we have a
responsibility to help these nations
move forward and to put into action a
plan a plan for security a plan for
prosperity in the region and this plan
must be based on the two State solution
a safe and secure Israel and an
independent Palestinian State the
Palestinians have the right to a stable
political future with a government that
has the interest of its people at heart
and a vision for a sustainable economic
future The palestin Authority will be
key to any future political settlement
and we the EU we are the main donor to
the palestin authority and we must
continue our strong support because
supporting a credible and legitimate
Palestinian Authority is an investment
in peace and Security in the
region ladies and gentlemen we have a
role to play in building peace in the
region through our diplomacy through our
convening power our common foreign
security policy instruments and our role
as a trusted globble
partner the EU was born From the Ashes
of four a peace Project based on
reconciliation and in these dark days of
violence and conflicts it's never too
early to talk about peace to be obsessed
by peace highes B launched the Peace Day
effort initiative in September in the
mar of the assembly together with Egypt
Jordan Saudi Arabia and the league of
Arab states and with some 50 countries
from around the world this initiative
must be expanded get getting our member
states and other partners like the US
involved we will work with all those who
believe in peace and want to work
together to fight the poison of
extremism and our efforts will be linked
with the normalization efforts already
under the way
because the EU is by nature a global
actor we will take the lead with others
in organizing as soon as possible a
peace and normalization Conference
inspired by previous peace initiatives
and the Abraham courts lasting peace in
the region will require peace between
Israelis and Palestinians and between
Israel and all its
neighbors ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues at this European council
meeting we also discussed the
consequences of this conflict for our
societies within the European Union and
we are seeing a in
anti-Semitism we condemn this in the
strongest possible terms because they go
against everything we stand for in
Europe discrimination and intolerance
have no place in our family of Nations
and we will always stand against racism
anti-Semitism islamophobia and all forms
of discriminations this why we have
tasked our ministers to coordinate and
take all appropriate action and measures
in this
respect
M
[Music]
so
guante
[Music]
for
Sol
POS
for
thank you very much uh president
Michelle the next speaker is the
European commission president Madame
urula velan
please thank you vice president marel um
president Char Michelle honorable
members the pain of innocent civilians
in the Middle East shakes the conscience
of the world the situation on the ground
is evolving fast so let me focus on the
work we have done since the October
European Council to fulfill this
mandate the essential starting point
continues to be what happened on the 7th
of October there is no justification for
the horror that Hamas Unleashed against
innocent men women children babies
Israel has the right to defend itself in
line with international law and
international humanitarian law
supporting Israel is essential but so is
aiding and protecting civilians in
Gaza the death toll and the suffering of
Palestinian civilians is tragic there
are images we cannot
unsee this shakes us to the core all of
us so while Israel has the right to
fight Hamas it is also essential that it
strives to avoid civilian casualties and
to be as targeted as possible because
every human life matters be it Israeli
or
Palestinian let me update you on our
humanitarian work two weeks ago we had
already tripled our Aid to
Gaza this week I have announced that we
are further increasing humanitarian uh
Aid by another 25 million e bringing
thus the total support to € 100 million
EUR and we are working hard for this Aid
to reach
Palestinians convis are now entering
Gaza through the rougher boarding border
crossing but the volume remains too
small to match the massive humanitarian
needs this is why we are working on a
maritime corridor from Cyprus
it would guarantee a sustained regulated
and robust flow of Aid I very much
welcome the excellent cooperation with
President Nikos Christo does and his
government this can make the difference
between life and death for thousands of
Palestinians and we will continue to
help evacuate EU citizens and injured
Palestinians honorable members as we
deal with the urgency of today we must
also make the effort to think about
tomorrow how to break the current spiral
of violence and how hope can be restored
for Israelis and
Palestinians they need a political
perspective and the perspective is the
two-state
solution of course in the end Israelis
and Palestinians will have to agree on
on a way
forward but we as part of the
international effort we must contribute
and of course in close cooperation with
our friends and our
partners I believe five principles for
the day after could help build some
common
ground first Gaza can be no safe heaven
for
terrorists and different ideas are being
discussed on how this can be ensured
second the terrorist organization Hamas
cannot control or govern
Gaza there should be only one
Palestinian Authority and one
Palestinian
State third no long-term Israeli
security presence in Gaza because Gaza
is essential part of any future
Palestinian State and the territory of
Gaza cannot be reduced or amputated in
any
way fourth no forc displacement of
Palestinians from
Gaza this would be humanitarian tragedy
and also a recipe for more Regional
instability and finally no sustained
blockade of Gaza any future Palestinian
state must be
viable also from an economic point of
view and Europe stands ready to work
with all people and countries in this
region to make this
happen I know that all of this may look
overly ambitious as the war rages on but
I think we must spare no effort to keep
the hope alive to find a lasting
solution based on two states living side
by side in peace and security it is
again time for an international effort
toward watch PE peace in Middle East and
we Europeans must play our
role honorable
members the European Council also
focused on
Ukraine I was in ke a few days
ago in recent weeks I had also the
chance to visit all the Western Balan
countries as well as
mova and how different these countries
are they all share one feeling they feel
they belong to the European Union there
is a new level of vision and ambition in
aspiring EU members they are ready to
work even harder to join our Union and
here in the union too there's a new
sense of urgency to unite our European
family today it is clear that the
stability of every country in our
continent affects of course also our own
stability their security is our
security and if our Union isn't fast
enough in bringing candidate countries
closer others will fill the
vacuum but it is in our geopolitical
interest to complete our Union to make
it stronger than ever and it's not only
about geopolitics it's of course also
about
economics the completion of our Union
will make the new member states
economies grow it will make EU companies
grow it will also make our single Market
grow making Europe an even more
attractive and stronger partner in the
global
stage Prosperity is not only shared by
enlargement it is Multiplied enlargement
is in our common interest so we must
seize this moment of opportunity to
advance as much as possible towards the
completion of our Union and today we
presented the enlargement report and let
me Briefly summarize some
results first on
Ukraine we are recommending to the
council to open accession
negotiations the progress that Ukraine
has made as it fights an existential war
is remarkable and impressive with with
very clear achievements on all seven
steps we have
identified well over 90% of those steps
have been
completed the remaining reforms are on
their way so by March 2024 we will
report back to the Council on these
ongoing reforms in order to have
everything ready to finalize the
negotiating framework very clear the
future of Ukraine is in our European
Union and this future has just
begun we also see mdova with its bold
efforts to come closer to
us and this has to be seen against the
backdrop of a war in the neighboring
Ukraine and of massive Russian
interference therefore the report
highlights the significant reforms mova
has
undertaken we also recommend to open
accession negotiations with mova and
here too some remaining measures are to
be finished and the commission will
report to Council on this by March and
on this basis the council could then
finalize the negotiating
framework for Bosnia and
heroa the commission
recognizes a number of positive
political and legal steps for example
the Swift entry into office of a new
Council of ministers in January of of
2023 you can see that this has brought
positive results there's progress in the
fight against organized crime in the
fight against money laundering and
terrorism for example but we also note
with concern the various
unconstitutional laws adopted by the
representatives of the Republica sska
entity so against these backdrops the
commission recommends to the council the
opening of accession negotiation ations
once the necessary degree of compliance
with the membership criteria is achieved
and here too the commission will report
to the Council on progress in by March
2024 finally
Georgia we see the European aspiration
of the overwhelming majority of its
citizens and while these aspirations
need to be better mirrored by the
authorities and and while further
progress is needed on the 12 priorities
identified last year the commission also
acknowledges a number of positive steps
and we should encourage Georgia to move
on so the commission recommends here to
Grant candidate status to Georgia on the
understanding that the government takes
important
reforms honorable
members today's package is not only a
snapshot of the situation ation on the
ground it can and it must be a driver of
change since the very beginning of the
Mandate I have deeply believed that we
needed to reboot the enlargement process
in particular with the Western Balkan so
road blacks and vetos were hampering the
progress towards the European Union
instead we should look at every country
how it is able to advance on the
association path
based on its own
merits every new a achievement should
lead them closer to us and with our new
growth plan that we also presented today
we're setting out very clearly more for
more you open your borders in your
common regional market we open our
single Market in seven very important
sectors you do the reforms for Level
Playing Field for your companies to
access the single Market we come with
investment to help you to implement
these
reforms so honorable members it is every
country's responsibility to turn the
page and make the Strategic choice for
Europe and of course in parallel we the
European Union also need to lay the
necessary internal groundwork on reforms
in other words let's get to work long
live Europe thank you thank you very
much Madame President fion and the first
speaker is Mr Secret